hola que tal bienvenidos una vez más a
esta emisión canadá en las américas café
en esta ocasión estamos aquí en el
estudio y hoy pienso que vayan abriendo
sus micrófonos
rufo valencia como ésta rufo con placer
estrenando estudios y estrenando año
visitando programa yo creo que es el
estudio el que nos está estrenando a
nosotros porque ya estaba ahí ya escuchó
entonces también a pablo gómez barrios
que también está hoy aquí en este
programa todo bien
todo bajo control afortunadamente a
pesar de esas temperaturas tan bajas que
ha habido en las últimas semanas pero
ahora estaba lloviendo estaba
derritiendo no hagan ninguna
especulación en esta noche comienza la
lluvia helada se mañana a 10 grados 15
grados y el domingo máxima 18 bajo cero
máxima y 25 grados
eso sí ese pájaro de mal agüero que
descubrirá solo lector de chanel del
weather channel
mi nombre es luis laborda les damos
entonces una vez más la bienvenida a
todos los que nos siguen a través de las
diversas plataformas con la que cuenta
canadá en las américas de café y radio
canadá internacional habitualmente
ustedes siguen nuestro programa a través
de nuestro sitio en internet los días
domingos ahora eso va a cambiar un poco
también le también tiene una posibilidad
hacerlo a través de facebook live y
aprovechamos entonces para saludar a
todos que nos están siguiendo por ese
canal
pero además sumamos más plataformas en
canal en las américas café y no
solamente es un programa ha escuchado a
través de dos vías sino que ahora
también les ofrecemos la posibilidad de
vernos en directo a través de nuestro
sitio en youtube exacto así que pueden
tener una posibilidad más para para
seguir nuestro programa y además a
partir de hoy ustedes habrán notado que
estamos en un día distinto al habitual
habitualmente grabamos esta emisión y
nos seguían por facebook live los días
jueves a partir de ahora va a ser los
días viernes a las 12 hora local de
invierno de montreal
este programa va hasta entonces
disponible no sé si a partir esta semana
sobre no lo puede explicar mucho mejor
que yo pero la idea es que esté
disponible a partir del momento en el
que se grabó poco después del momento en
el que se graba durante el resto del
viernes sábado y domingo decir todo el
fin de semana fue el programa en nuestro
sitio internet para todos aquellos que
lo quieran escuchar esas y leonardo
estoy mintiendo me parece así ahora está
disponible en realidad justamente la
emisión se va a transmitir por dos
plataformas diferentes y una de esas
plataformas las va a ser tomada por
nuestro sitio web es decir que a partir
la semana que viene si todo sale como
como pensado como programado va a ser
facebook live youtube youtube live y en
el sitio de internet de radio canal
internacional se va a desplazar el
carrusel hacia abajo y va a aparecer el
vídeo de esta emisión en el momento que
esté en vivo después lo van a poder ir a
buscar en los lugares habituales ahora
yo sé que en el caso de youtube
estábamos más que nada probando y cómo
será la cosa pero la emisión ya va a
quedar el canal va a quedar inaugurado
oficialmente ese de hoy y todo lo todas
las semanas youtube estará ofreciendo
nuestro programa
sí exacto exacto que queda inaugurado y
vamos a empezar a darle promoción
también voy a poner el link para que la
gente pueda ir a vernos en el sitio de
youtube en español perfecto muy bien
entonces una vez hecha esta presentación
y una vez hecha entonces esta aclaración
y habiendo los informados de esta
novedad cambio de día sumamos
plataformas más canales para que sigan
entonces a canadá en las américas café y
a todo el contenido de radio canadá
internacional les propongo entonces que
nos aboquemos a discutir cuáles son los
temas que les han llamado la atención
creo que a aquellos que salen de lo
común durante los últimos días pues más
que todo una pregunta en mi caso y es
algo que hablábamos justamente antes de
que empiece el programa y era justamente
saber si si los osos y todos los osos
hibernan están activas
las respectivas
y pues están los osos grizzly y los osos
polares los osos negros pero nos explica
nuestro colega leonardo quien era no no
no hibernan duermen duermen
profundamente pero no hibernan no es
esta donación estado hibernación implica
que la temperatura el cuerpo baje
muchísimo que baje también la
y el ritmo cardíaco sólo algunos latidos
por minuto y evidentemente eso según las
investigaciones no lo hacen los osos lo
hacen ciertos tipos de animales que son
en realidad muy pequeños digamos en la
microfauna esto sucede la hibernación
como tal el hecho de bajar el ritmo
cardíaco y entrar en una temperatura que
permite que el cuerpo quede
completamente sumido en ese sopor
durante cierto tiempo y después de esta
investigación los osos no hacen eso
lugar me profundamente a veces como una
redefinición de la hibernación porque me
acuerdo que en aquella época ya los que
son de mi edad
pensarán lo mismo es que la hibernación
era simplemente cuando se recogían
durante el invierno y volvían a salir
meses más tarde no claro que ese es el
caso por ejemplo de los de los grizzlies
pero en todo caso dejando de lado los
osos y viendo algo más más modesto y
menos menos impresionante tomando en
cuenta que hemos tenido temperaturas de
25 t integrado bajo cero por varios días
consecutivos la pregunta era cómo es
posible que al llegar el verano vuelvan
las hormigas y aún más tomando en cuenta
que están son mineros bajo tierra que
está la filtración de la nieve entonces
te pones a pensar y es un trabajo de
trabajo de ingeniería fantástico porque
buen año mal año las hormigas siempre
vuelven todo esto pues justamente porque
uno piensa que pueden hacer al tema que
voy a hablar más tarde pero ahí esta
noción del invierno que solamente una
suma de días fríos pero al interior de
ese de esos meses invernales aquí en el
norte de nuestro continente
el invierno es una puerta para un sinfín
de misterios preguntas y maravillas
bueno en ese tema
siguen agregándole una veta más a esta
cuestión en todo caso a mí lo que
siempre me llamó la atención es como una
vez que se retira la nieve y el frío
cuando llega la primavera por estas
latitudes vuelve a resurgir la
vegetación con la fuerza y el colorido
que lo hace cada año uno supone o yo
supongo por lo menos creía así en todo
caso cuando llegue que teniendo un metro
de nieve o más como yo tengo mi patio
delantero en este momento en el césped
las flores tan bonitas que yo vi en el
verano las plantas que uno había
cultivado con tanto cariño se moría
quedaban quemadas por el frío y por la
nieve y sin embargo con dos manuales
hay de todo sancionador porque las
perennes en principio deberían volver a
renacer bueno exactamente eso se llaman
así y lo que a uno le llama la atención
es que esos seres tan diminutos no
quiere que son las plantas en este caso
las plantas perennes como dice pablo
vuelven a nacer con un color y con un
brillo como si por encima de los pasados
más que una leve
con todo este frío es justamente lo que
ha hecho leonardo y lo que he hecho por
primera vez en mi vida es recibir el año
nuevo con 35 38 bajo cero más o menos
haciendo una parrillada a esos
interesante si sabía muy bien lo
impecable pero era verano y que te llevó
a experimentar y saiz a esa aventura
este año pensé en salir a celebrar como
locamente lo hacía en tiempos previos
pero dije me gusta es expresión
locamente pero opté por hacer algo más
arriesgado y es mantener un fuego y con
ser una carne conocimiento así que creo
que fue algo que quizá lo vuelva a
repetir pero lo nado aquí es el veterano
de la familia
no paró nunca el único problema es que
cada vez se acumula más nieve alrededor
de mi partida porque hay lugares donde
no puede llegar con la pala entonces
cada vez se dificulta más el acceso y
abrir la parrilla vas a acabar con un
iglú
probablemente la idea pero financiero no
sé si con las bombas de gas a la
permitió aquí se hace por lo general y
yo recuerdo que cuando llegue alguien me
dijo cosas que después verifique que no
era cierto que era peligroso
enseñarle al árbitro durante el invierno
porque esta famosa garrafa bomba de
propano podía estallar pero porque cuál
era la razón no sé pero si estallan y
eso está allá y eso aquí me lo dijo era
porque a veces se desconectan los tubos
del cs para la garrafa de los conductos
de gas de la apropiada y en los
edificios alegan por ahí lo que ocurre
es que se las arañas hacen sus nidos ahí
adentro en el tubo bloquean y es ahí
cuando arde arde parís y las arañas ni
berna claro que no duermen por eso se
pone en lugares calentitos
así no tenían que bajar la temperatura
la demostración de que no siempre está
precisamente a leonardo de siempre
nuestros amigos estarán preguntando y
estos locos de que están hablando si
estamos mirando estamos hablando de
algunas cosas que justamente cuando uno
vive en américa latina pues no la
suspendió la sospecha por ejemplo esto
de preguntarse qué pasa con las hormigas
en invierno así que yo creo que la
próxima vez que vea un hormiga pues
pensarán que acuérdense de que estas
hormigas sobreviven sin calcetines ni
botas ni bufandas los 35 grados bajo
cero
perfecto algún otro tema que querían
comentar no sé dónde en realidad no me
quedó claro dónde pero hay un país
nórdico de estos de estos del primer
primer primerísimo mundo que están
haciendo carreteras bicisendas en
realidad todavía con papel higiénico
usado porque hasta el momento es
imposible exacto justamente por eso
porque la contaminación que produce el
hecho de
el papel higiénico no todo se deshace lo
que no se deshace lo tienen que secar y
después quemarlo esa quema de papel
higiénico está contaminando el planeta
una más de las cosas que contaminan el
planeta en este caso están haciendo un
proyecto piloto para tratar de
reutilizar eso entonces pasa un proceso
y termina que obviamente es un proceso
químico que no entiendo pero termina en
una masa grisácea normaron hacia una
especie papel maché y con eso están
haciendo la parte que correspondería al
asfalto de las bicisendas en este lugar
si me dan dos segundos pero bien hay un
país escandinavo
que está digamos utilizando como materia
prima para sus ciclovías bicisendas y es
un proyecto no todas entonces en un
futuro lo que resulta papel higiénico
usado
y reciclado
inicial de la información entrar en
detalles quizás un poco más llenos de
color
de la casa blanca en los momentos
exactos y hablando de casablanca
rufo rufo me hace pensar en esta noticia
insólita hasta cierto punto y fueron
estas declaraciones que hizo ayer en una
reunión sobre la inmigración en la que
estaban participando algunos
congresistas de estadounidenses y al
parecer el presidente de trump había
tratado a haití el salvador y algunos
países africanos de países de [ __ ] así
simple fue la nación que esa fue la
expresión que lo utilizó antes de
publicar la noticia y de ponerla en
nuestro sitio estuve haciendo una una
búsqueda en internet para ver cómo
habían traducido
los otros medios en esa expresión y
finalmente es la expresión que fue
utilizada esta mañana el presidente de
trump salió diciendo en su primer tweet
que envió porque siempre envía sus
tweets temprano muy temprano en la
mañana entonces diciendo que o
pretendiendo al menos que el que eso no
fue lo que él dijo que él utilizó si un
lenguaje muy duro para referirse a estos
países pero que no utilizó esos términos
entonces pues esta noticia le ha dado la
vuelta al mundo países africanos están
reaccionando desde desde esta mañana
naciones unidas condenó está esta
declaración de trump que califica de
descortés e inaceptable en todo caso hay
algunos congresistas latinos de origen
latinoamericano y de origen haitiano
incluso que han protestado y que han
dicho que pues no es la mejor forma
digamos de aportar el tema de la
inmigración y de referirse de esa forma
de los países de los que son originarios
esta inmigración que se tratar y si
solamente un insulto y es imán suelto
contra emi gracia y llanamente labial y
además más allá de este insulto puntual
el problema creo que va siendo contra mí
es que es alguien que está rompiendo
hasta las mínimas normas de coexistencia
de convivencia y de vivir y de llevar
adelante la política sobre todo cómo se
trata nada más y nada menos que el
presidente de un país es él quien
después representa eeuu y quien deberá
verse con mandatarios colegas de otros
países que pueden gustarle o no gustarle
para gestionar los distintos temas que
pueden interesar a una y otra nación
entonces con qué cara podría ir después
a negociar a enfrentar a visitar a lo
que sea a un mandatario de un país al
cual de insultar de una manera tan
grosera como la que acaba de hacer y
creo que el problema más que quizás es
que cada vez más y más evidente y algo
que se sale mencionado en un libro sobre
el que tú vas a hablar un libro que
salió hace poco de frankfurt
el problema que creo que el mundo tiene
en este momento es que está si está
tratando de
se considera que la persona en la casa
blanca es una persona en sus cabales lo
que cada vez más y más muestras de que
es una persona que no tiene los recursos
intelectuales como para para inclusive
para poder escribir un poco más de lo
que escribe diariamente en el tweet es
decir no es una persona que
racionalmente actuaría de esa forma
entonces pedirle una persona sin
racionalidad y cortesía y principios
básicos de coexistencia es pedirle en
persona
evidentemente ya no tiene estructuras
mentales que le permitan ser coherente
el problema es que su incoherencia la
expresa como vos acaba de decir todos
los días a través de una catarata de
verborragia sin sentir otra vez que para
manejar cuestiones de estado que después
de las que después va a ser muy difícil
volver para atrás sea me lo que me llama
la atención y me lastima más y me da
mucho más miedo es que la gente lo
eligió
bueno ese es el problema o sea hay un
montón de gente que piensa como él
evidentemente yo no sé si al límite del
leve de la falta de respeto total como
lo hace él pero hay un montón de gente
que lo apoya que lo sigue apoyando
evidentemente y que está ahí o sea está
ahí no porque él se le antojó va si se
le antojó y llegó pero le dijeron hace
te antoja bueno llegar por los por los
por las vías que corresponden y lo hizo
pero y creo que sí es cierto pero quizá
lo que está inclusive atrás de esto es
la propia la propia estructura o lo que
se llama la democracia en eeuu la
democracia en general que se muestra
cada vez más y más de que la democracia
tal como se la practica no es suficiente
como para atender los problemas de la
sociedad la democracia actualmente
funciona así realmente es como te pone
un steak un asado delante de ti y te dan
a escoger un tenedor de plástico con dos
dientes o un tenedor de plástico sin
diente alguno y la democracia es
justamente cuál de los dos va a escoger
dentro de esas expresiones que tienen
de esta manera porque a veces expresa
que parecería ser que no tiene razón
yo publique una noticia de esta mañana
también a partir de declaraciones que
hizo en twitter pero además de un gesto
político que creo que tiene mucha más
trascendencia de la que se le ha dado
hasta el momento canceló en las últimas
horas la visita programada a gran
bretaña de la que se venía hablando
desde hacía meses y meses que en el
transcurso de esa visita a londres tenía
que inaugurar estaba previsto que
inaugurar la nueva sede de la embajada
de eeuu frente a gran bretaña un
edificio que fue ordenado durante la
administración de obama y cuya
construcción costó más allá de 1.200
millones de dólares y bueno desde hacía
tiempo se decía que si trump realmente
desembarcaba en londres iba a haber
protestas y que algunas de ellas podrían
llegar a ser violentas tal vez y
entonces trump decidió cancelar su
visita y el argumento que utilizó para
cancelar esa visita es que él no estaba
de acuerdo con la mudanza y la embajada
porque se iba del barrio de mayfair que
es una zona
fingida cara de embajada de londres
exacto a una zona que él definió como
periférica no es verdad que sea
periférica no lo es pero que no está
dentro del centro de londres entonces él
consideraba que no valía la pena esta
mudanza que se estaba abandona en un
edificio muy caro y muy distinguido tal
vez la mejor embajada que con la que
cuenta la ciudad de londres
entre todas las que se encuentran allí
es decir alguien que anula una visita de
estado a su principal socio político y
comercial y argumenta que esa
cancelación se debe a que no está de
acuerdo con el barrio elegido para la
nueva sede de la embajada
bueno yo creo que ya no queda mucho
calificas habría sido más elegante
culpar al conejo de alicia de las
maravillas porque estaba muy apurado
por el momento
holanda ingenio alan de si se utiliza
papel higiénico usado para construir
bicisendas
para concluir con el amigo
trump el precisamente su forma de
manejarse y su forma de llevar adelante
la administración del gobierno dio
origen a un libro el que al que muestra
referiste hace instantes rufo que es
frankfurt y fuego y furia y así así
habría que así se traduce es así ha sido
ya ha traducido al español en todo caso
que cuenta los entretelones de los
primeros días de la administración de
trump han llegado a la casa blanca en
enero del año pasado en el 2017 este
libro por supuesto apenas salió a la
venta fue arrebatado de las góndolas de
todas las librerías en poquitas boxeo
como hablan caliente se vendió como pan
caliente efectivamente como el que todo
el mundo nuevo
todo el mundo quería enterarse de los
entretelones escritos por alguien que
aparentemente había
según dice el autor de ese libro
recolectó desde la voz de los propios
protagonistas y tenía carta blanca en la
casa blanquilla y se paseó por la casa
blanca cuado a gusto y piacere
efectivamente el emperador de abisinia
por abhisit y efectivamente este otro
libro este libro del mejor dicho le dio
la posibilidad a un autor canadiense que
escribió un libro con un título que en
parte se parece porque tienes la primera
parte del título es la misma es fuego y
furia pero es un libro que se refiere en
todo caso a hechos relacionados con la
segunda guerra mundial a la situación de
la población alemana en la durante la
segunda guerra mundial y este autor
canadiense randall hansen de golpe y
porrazo se vio sorprendido por un libro
que él había escrito con un tipo similar
a este otro hace más de una década y
empezó a ser vendido como dice pablo
como pan caliente si la gente empezó a
encargar a través de los sitios de en
línea pero por confusión con el tipo de
confusión con el título entonces el
libro
en las ventas se empezó a hablar de él
en todo en todos lados y hubo gente que
hasta inclusive comenzó a analizarlo sin
darse cuenta de que en ningún momento
hacía referencia a la administración
transba bla bla en todo caso es un hecho
relacionado con la segunda guerra
mundial si varios justamente a propósito
del libro escrito por el canadiense hay
varios historiadores que han puesto
sobre la mesa y han han puestos nuevos
elementos para considerar las políticas
de los aliados las las las tácticas la
estrategia militar de los bombardeos a
ciudades civiles en alemania donde no
había objetivos militares se trata de
ciudades como hamburgo resten por
ejemplo en que un bombardeo costó más de
cerca de 200 y más de 100 mil 150 mil
muertos y para muchos historiadores esa
era una medida desproporcionada y lo que
la lógica que se aplicaba en ese momento
era justamente de desmoralizar a los
alemanes a través de masivos bombardeos
civiles que a la luz de los segundos
criterios actuales serían crímenes de
guerra y eso es lo que algunos
historiadores sostienen
de los bombardeos aliados contra
ciudades de alemania durante la segunda
guerra mundial el libro de grand
alliance and se titula fuego y furia el
bombardeo aliado de alemania desde 1942
hasta 1945 y se encuentra en este
momento para el día de autor agotado
tenemos amigos salvadoreños que están
siguiendo nuestro programa para ver cuál
es su justamente su opinión sobre sobre
lo que se escuchan de eeuu la casa blava
en realidad tenemos aquí a javier
gonzález nunca nadie que dice con el
cambio de día y ahora pendiente del
programa porque se puso a esperar antes
en nuestro sitio
y después dice saludos a mi paisana
palabra martínez aquí esperando la
transmisión así que un saludo para
javier un saludo para paloma que pasó
nos miró desde allí saludamos y se fue a
continuar con su trabajo y después
tenemos a gilberto martínez desde
nicaragua que dice saludos y luis
balderas desde puerto de san antonio en
chile que también están mirando en este
momento de la misión mientras también
nelson contreras rincón desde
barranquilla colombia él dice buenas
tardes saludos desde colombia y bueno
pues eso es todo por el momento muy bien
[Música]
más
bueno perfecto entonces he dejado ya el
amigo atrás atrás y antes de entrar en
los temas que hemos estado trabajando
durante esta semana porque no damos
lectura a algunos otros mensajes de
nuestros oyentes aquellos que nos han
llegado a nuestro sitio internet www
jersey net punto sea barra e s de
español y que son numerosos algunos de
ellos ya hace tiempo que los tenemos
aquí guardados y hay crearlos tema
historia del baile y la rueda de casino
salsa concepción coca nos dice dónde
pueden escribir me tengo una fractura de
hueso y necesito una operación urgente
no entendí me parece que debe ser otro
tema en este caso otro pequeño mensaje
como son los primeros días de los
solicitantes de refugio en canadá y la
ayuda que reciben álvaro dice en
respuesta a andrés si ha sido amenazado
si aplica pero debe demostrarlo esto es
supongo que que en una charla que tiene
que ver
solicite la solicitud de refugio para
entrar a canadá baja y con respecto a
ola de intenso frío provocó la
congelación de tuberías en edificios e
infraestructuras javier gonzález en un
garaje justamente dice con estas
temperaturas de 30 o más grados
centígrados bajo cero de veras que se
complican las cosas y la vida de los
habitantes de algunos lugares de canadá
nunca he vivido una situación así pero
creo que es muy pero muy difícil deseo
que esto pase rápido saludos
era un mensaje de javier gonzález nunca
eran muchas gracias aquí tenemos un
mensaje de nuestro amigo jordi quien
opina largamente sobre el referéndum por
la independencia en cataluña el fin de
españa y él dice y ganamos el referéndum
del primero de octubre y ganamos las
elecciones del 21 de diciembre del 2017
que el gobierno impuso por la fuerza se
refiere a lamadrid españa dice jordi es
un país corrupto partido popular partido
socialista y ciudadanos son un complot
de la espanya triste gris y profunda del
franquismo
y comprados los que se oponen se les
echa por ejemplo baltasar garzón garzón
y se les prohíbe ejercer durante 20 años
pues él pidió silva que sentó al
banquillo al señor blesa amigo de aznar
hace de abogado en barcelona ahora en
2018 porque es el hecho de la
adjudicatura es una vergüenza es una
pena
españa debe mil trescientos mil
trescientos mil mil trescientos mil
millones de euros más o menos es
imposible que lo amorticen nunca las
pensiones son pequeñas pero van a
desaparecer en el futuro españa vive de
las subvenciones de la unión europea y
de los impuestos de catalunya catalunya
hace más de 300 años que intenta dejar
españa y nos han matado matado a
presidentes fusilado a gente
como he dicho este periodista español
tiene mis respetos hablando seguro que
podríamos seguir juntos pero creo que
españa desaparecerá y la corruptela del
partido popular tendrá mucho que ver y
la unión europea mira y no hace nada
cuando todo reviente entonces se
lamentará todo el mundo pero españa
habrá desaparecido como lo conocemos
políticamente físicamente estará allí y
espero que todos los corruptos queden
encerrados
la hija del ex rey y en suiza con su
marido urdangarín mientras que españa
quien españa incluso ellos robaron
increíble un saludo desde cataluña jordi
un amigo así que hoy cuando imprimía los
mensajes que nos hicieron llegar en los
últimos días los oyentes me encontré al
menos con cuatro o cinco mensajes
larguísimos cada uno más o menos de una
carilla donde los autores con toda la
potestad que les compete aprovecharon
para expresarse sobre distintos temas yo
tengo aquí un mensaje de wilfredo
montilla que también es más largo de lo
que yo voy a leer pero dice en sus
primeras líneas en relación a
en venezuela el salario mínimo aumentó a
un 40% esos tienen buenos dias ese
aumento de salario es irrisorio en
comparación a la pésima situación
económica que atraviesa el país y sobre
todo sus trabajadores si continúa con su
mensaje muy bien estos son alguno de los
mensajes que nos han llegado hasta ahora
vamos a seguir leyendo los más tarde en
tiempo que todavía tenemos en nuestra
emisión pero ahora les propongo a
ustedes que les presentemos a nuestro
público aquellos temas en los que hemos
estado trabajando durante los últimos
días y que ustedes quisieran destacar de
todos aquellos que han producido quien
quiere comenzar a hablar hablaremos del
próximo lunes el lunes 15 que
supuestamente es el día más más triste
de todo el año si esa es la teoría que
circula y justamente averigüe por
ejemplo que fue un profesor
universitario en inglaterra y que ha
pedido de una compañía de viajes que
habían pedido que detecte que establezca
cuál es el día más propicio para vender
billetes de paquetes de vacaciones
billetes de avión para ir a la playa
es decir salir de esa misma he no leza
de una de un londres gris y frío de
invierno o de canadá para mí hace frío
en invierno entonces él con una técnica
dudosa pero en fin en el mercadeo
funciona todo entonces hizo creer que el
el tercer lunes de enero es el lunes más
triste del año porque es la fecha en la
que más o menos llegue a las cuentas de
las tarjetas de crédito es el lunes la
tercera semana en cuando en donde la
gente se da cuenta que en el fondo no va
a poder llevar a cabo esas primeras
intenciones para año nuevo
y otra y otra razón es que en muchos
casos la gente que está preocupada por
el peso se encuentra que después de las
comilonas de fin de año pues se
encuentra que ésta está pues con unos
kilos más unas libras más por lo menos
unos gramos más entonces todas esas
además que está siendo frío y está
lluvioso está nevando o está gris hay
menos luz de día entonces toda esta
acumulación de factores así que
es el lunes tercer tercer lunes de enero
o sea el día más triste del año igual ha
hecho escuché en la radio en la radio
anglófona aquí en montreal que hablaban
de si usted no se divorció hasta el 12
de enero este año no se divorcia o por
lo menos hay más muchas menos
posibilidades o divorcios porque en
realidad es justamente con las
resoluciones de año nuevo de edad con
los gastos que se hicieron cuestiones
monetarias familiares haber ido a comer
a la casa de los padres de ellos los
padres de él
todo eso aumenta el riesgo y parece que
hasta el 12 de enero es cuando la gente
toma coraje y dice claro
hay menos mucho menos peligroso
segurísimo divorcia cualquiera en
cualquier momento al el 12 de enero y ya
seguramente la pareja habrá perdonado el
que uno se equivocó de nombre por
ejemplo después viene el 3er
y entonces justamente ante esa situación
una galería de arte montreal dirigida
por una pintora chilena carolina
echeverría
creo que la galería se llama galería
metec en referencia una canción de joe
gusta aquí que justamente hace tomar la
palabra antigua palabra griega meteco
que es el nombre del extranjero que no
tiene derechos en la en la polis en la
ciudad griega es decir es un espacio
para que se expresen la
pluriculturalidad canadiense y entonces
organice este lunes una presentación de
arte plástico más músicos que van a
interpretar una canción una versión suya
de una canción que hace parte de la de
la historia de la música en quebec es
una canción que al in the blues calling
the blues
que son traducidas que decir [ __ ]
[ __ ] tristeza que vamos a escuchar
cerrando este mismo no exactamente
entonces tomando ese tomando en cuenta
[ __ ] tristeza que es esa que ocurre
que supuestamente ocurre el próximo
pues ese día habrá música y habrá
pintura habrán telas y pues bueno una
forma de justamente de superar de reírse
de la pena común como como ocurre con
algunos tangos no hay que en que uno
busca paliar esa desazón con un poco de
tango profundizan de georges moustaki y
de emt que y me vino inmediatamente a la
mente el inicio de esa canción que es
además el de mt que digite schramm y
postre
bueno que sería con mi cara de met eco
de judío errante y de apóstol griego y
los cabellos a los cuatro vientos
entonces no nada es que cuando él
hablaba de eso me puse a pensar en esa
canción que en una época escuchaba
muchísimo cuando llegué aquí
a canadá por allá en la década de los 70
y esta canción es de justamente de los
años 70 se compone el 71 justamente esta
canción de joe biden jay bubble bueno
hacía parte de un grupo que se llamaba
offenbach así es entonces bueno y por mi
parte pues yo los quiero invitar a
escuchar una entrevista que hice con una
chica colombiana emprendedora que llegó
aquí a canadá en el 2008 con su familia
llegó el padre la madre ella hay dos
hermanas después vino otra hermana que
se vive se vino a juntar con ellos acá y
esta chica bueno hizo sus estudios acá
en quebec y en un momento dado
tenía bueno estudio en comunicaciones
y en inmigración y quería en ciencias
políticas de inmigración y se estaba
dirigiendo hacia hacia esa carrera no
pero de pronto sentada en un café se le
ocurrió que quería hacer otra cosa de
golpe o tomar mucha fe y tomar un buen
café entonces él preparó un plan de
negocios para importar café colombiano
aquí a canadá y bueno preparó todo
preparó muy bien todo su plan de
negocios y finalmente pues empezó en el
2016 llegó su primera su primer
contenedor con 20 toneladas de café 100%
colombiano el café se llama mar e igual
que es una palabra de los arahuacos los
indígenas arhuacos de la sierra nevada
de la de colombia en el norte y su
compañía se llama mar agua que les está
yendo muy bien es una historia exitosa
una empresaria que ahora ya le ha
generado empleo para ella misma para sus
familiares y tiene además empleados que
están trabajando para ella está
trabajando con en el comercio equitativo
así que van a comprar directamente el
café a la sierra nevada en colombia y
hacen negocio directamente con los
productores entonces ese era una de las
condiciones que tenía que cumplir ese
compromiso y contamos a hacer además que
también están en planes de expansión hay
planes de expansión exacto por el
momento están en una pequeña ciudad acá
que está como unos 50 minutos de
montreal se llama central y
hay otros hay planes de expansión pero
decía en la entrevista que no puede
hablar por el momento de esos planes
pero bueno pese es interesante ver el
recorrido no que llega a esta familia
que llegó acá en el 2008 y que hoy en
día pues se están generando empleo
perfecto
nueva cápsula inteligente que podría
revolucionar el diagnóstico de
trastornos gastrointestinales
si una cápsula que en realidad tiene un
robot adentro y uno se la toma como si
fuera una pastilla y el robot es
exactamente lo que necesita la cápsula
bueno pero en el sitio te pongo un vídeo
de justamente de este testeo que se hace
ahí lo voy a poner sin sonido para que
ustedes puedan ver de qué se trata o por
lo menos lo que están haciendo es para
detectar todo tipo de problemas y han
encontrado ya cosas que no se sabían del
tracto gastrointestinal y de de
componentes y de cuestiones que no
habían sido investigadas hasta ahora
gracias a este robot este robot que uno
puede ver los resultados dentro del
teléfono con una aplicación telefónica
está bien y lo interesante de esto es
que podría si se mejora y se hace un
poco quizás un poco más chiquito porque
a pablo le costaría tragar semejante al
robot si semejante pastilla podría
evitar todos los tipos de tratamientos y
de análisis invasivos como la
colonoscopia y ese tipo de cosas que son
realmente bastante inconfortable para el
paciente así que este es un nuevo un
nuevo elemento para lograr bueno en
realidad justamente la historia es
tratar de evitar enfermedades y
encontrar otras para que sean curables
como por ejemplo el cáncer de colon y
después de las cápsulas al parecer
vienen los supositorios bueno mientras
en tecnologías que no lo piratean al
robot todo bien exacto es muy
rápidamente porque nos queda ya poco
tiempo yo les acerco una entrevista que
le hice a emily jolie y que es
integrante del frente de acción popular
por la reorganización urbana fra plus
que habla de la problemática de los
inmuebles insalubres en la ciudad de
montreal la flamante administración de
gobierno de montreal acaba de
decidir un incremento del presupuesto
destinado a la inspección de estas
viviendas porque aunque parezca difícil
creerlo en una ciudad tan importante
como montreal y en un país tan
desarrollado como canadá hay muchos
propietarios que ofrecen al mercado del
alquiler viviendas que realmente no no
respetan ni siquiera las normas básicas
de habitabilidad entonces los habitantes
los los inquilinos se encuentran con
cañerías que no funcionan con
inundaciones de sus unidades con
ventanas aisladas que les permiten
entrar a estos 30 grados de temperatura
bajo cero de los que le vamos a hacer un
rato con insectos con cucarachas con
roedores la municipalidad se ha tomado
el compromiso de
a hacer más estrictas las normas y de
hacer cumplir las que ya existen y uno
de esos uno de los recursos a los que va
a apelar entonces va a ser duplicar la
cantidad de inspectores que se ocupan de
verificar el estado de las viviendas de
alquiler en la ciudad que hasta el
momento son solamente 17 van a pasar a
ser cerca de 40 y el frap entiende que
esta medida no alcanza a satisfacer las
necesidades buenos días mi nombre es
claudia saldivia director musical del
conjunto proyecto altiplano y los invito
a escuchar canadá en las américas café
de radio canadá internacional muy bien
no nos queda ya casi tiempo así que si
tienen algún mensaje muy corto si yo
tengo acá uno cortísimo nos lo envía
nelson contreras rincón desde
barranquilla colombia y con respecto al
tema que evocamos ya él dice
lamentablemente las declaraciones del
señor trump no lamentable las
declaraciones del señor trump pero todas
sus actuaciones y declaraciones se
esperaban el pueblo lo eligió ojalá que
se pasen rápido
cuatro años y que no sea reelegido con
este colega con nuestro amigo josé
javier gonzález nunca dice refiriéndose
a la negociación del télica no dice se
viene la sexta ronda de negociaciones
del tratado de libre comercio de américa
del norte hay una incertidumbre tanto
para méxico como para canadá y yo dice
él como ciudadano mexicano
me gustaría que con el tratado o sin el
tratado continúen los movimientos
económicos entre eeuu y méxico pero que
las exportaciones de méxico la mayoría
va para eeuu el 80% por consiguiente
esto nos podría perjudicar saludos a
todos en el castor cibernético dice
javier gonzalo and drive en las últimas
horas esa incertidumbre se ha reducido
un poco pero para peor parecería hacer
cada vez más más posible de que eeuu
terminó retirándose de ese tratado
si aquí una pequeña habrá estado dice
gustaría tener más información de cómo
emigrar a canadá los pasos a seguir y
todos los relacionados de venezolana y
actualmente estoy en colombia sería mi
país por razones políticas no se escribe
germán 12 el pingo mon
y le contamos a rafael que nosotros no
podemos hacer nada desde el radical
internacional pero que en nuestros
artículos siempre intentamos poner todos
los vínculos para los lugares donde dan
toda la información oficial bueno muy
bien esto ha sido todo por hoy no nos
queda ya más tiempo les recordamos que a
partir de hoy nos quieren nos pueden
seguir a través de facebook lite los
días viernes y que también tienen la
plataforma de youtube a través del cual
nos pueden seguir en canadá en las
américas café muchísimas gracias a todos
y sera
hasta la próxima calling the blues de la
canción
[Música]